we're back here at South by Southwest
we're in Austin and we are here thanks
to our wonderful sponsors like we've got
hit water and we have Commissario
tequila thank you guys so much for
letting us be here because that means we
get to talk about movies like tone-deaf
and here are the filmmakers right here
huge congratulations on the movie thank
you for spending some time with us today
Thank You Perry thank you thank you you
left out one sponsor I'm not aware of
that one to be a boss on the table so
shout out to line 39 also for sponsoring
where's who is the persons behind this
one comma sorry oh yeah well we were
theorizing that it was George Clooney
actually a room I got you've got you've
got the in on that one you'll have to
clear that up by the so your movie
tone-deaf there are a whole bunch of
things going on in this movie and I'm
just curious what is the little nugget
of an idea that kind of spawned this
whole thing so there's this painting
called the connoisseur by Norman
Rockwell where this old fella is looking
at a Jackson Pollock painting and it's
kind of you know it's it was actually
satirical he was taking like a stab at
like Abstract Expressionism
so the idea whole like idea of that is
is what spawned the character of Harvey
and you sort of wrote this this movie
about it this sort of the idea that even
someone is talented and incredible as
Norman Rockwell was disillusioned by
this new wave of art that was you know
happening so I'm so curious to get your
takes when you first read the script for
the first time cuz there are so many
things that I saw in the movie that I
imagined her a little challenging to
visualize when you're just reading a
script so what happens when you read
through that the first time and what
kind of questions did you walk away with
that read with well when I was sent the
script I you know you get a breakdown
and it was kind of pitch to me as like a
horror thriller movie so I started
reading it as a traditional horror
thriller movie
and I didn't get it I was like what is
this this is awful
just playing off the line from the movie
um and but I was really I was just
really confused because I was reading it
as a traditional horror movie and so
then I googled Ricky and checked out the
trailers to his past films and I was
like oh this is what he's doing like
this is his voice and I love like I saw
these trailers I'm like these look so
cool so then then I was like I gotta go
back and read it again and reading it in
under that guys like that frame of his
tone pun intended and and then I was
like oh this okay I and I was so excited
about it but the first time I read it I
did not get it because I was just
thinking of it as a traditional horror
movie that's the usual response that
that's the usual response ah
so just to even get these movies made
though I have to make this like this is
a little tip for filmmakers you have to
make this just [ __ ] look look where
you say that you're making a horror
movie and then you don't you don't
necessarily do that exactly but you
can't get financing if you are if you're
crossing genres because everyone's
afraid of that you know and we're like
Sant we sample genres I'm gonna go John
rosanna rosanna noir genre so so you
have this lookbook and then you have
these bizarre scripts and then and then
I meet with the actors as I said [ __ ]
ignoring that look book that's what
that's how we got financed now let's
move move on and make the movie does
that do anything for you yeah it's just
it's an interesting process and not to
cut you off but I was just having a
conversation with Xander and Jackson
before and we kind of got into the idea
of risk-taking in film and the
importance of all these streaming
services that are rising up because
those are the companies that are taking
a chance on a different movie like this
so now I'm just curious to kind of get
your take on how the industry is
changing and kind of what doors are
opening up for you especially having
seen some of your other films do you
find that there's more opportunities to
make things like this now well I don't
really know what I don't really leave my
apartment that much
so I really know what's going on but
people seem to be doing well and a
Robert a question this guy's got some
craze my well what was your first take
on your character and in particular I'm
curious how you read some of the stuff
that maybe took place and like I don't
know if I would call it an otherworldly
zone but certain colorful material you
get to work with and some of the
breaking of the fourth wall stuff yeah
that's all those very great question
reading in it but it was an overwhelming
script to take in and try to comprehend
and follow what was going to be going on
with my character I in in you know
investigated Ricky a little bit got some
information about him looked at some of
his past work I admired the fact that he
came from my UI you know he had a lot of
people back at him and saying wonderful
things about him but when you got into
the words and what he was trying to say
and what the scripts about I feel like
it's very timely and it's a part of you
know our world right now our culture and
and it seemed like a timely piece done
in a very very clever way that would be
entertaining and as he said cross-genre
Xand and I was looking personally for
something you know totally different
than what I was doing on my day job
working on network TV and this just
totally blew my mind it felt very risky
for me to do and break the fourth wall
and some of the things that he had me do
I you know i had to just put my
confidence in him but he won me over in
a Skype session
face time you know he doesn't yeah so so
we had to do it but he was such a
charming young guy and I really believed
in him and I really made the decision
while I was talking to him on a computer
I wasn't sure but I liked him and I'm
glad I went down the the rabbit hole
with him there there were so many scenes
where I'd call cut and Robert would go
never done that before
rinse washed repeated so often it's a
very unique film this is you know yet it
didn't to see it and watch it and it's
very very unique and that's what I love
about it it's people are gonna be blown
away when they see it it doesn't fit
into the the normal how would you what
would you say it's it's it it turns it
upside down a little bit it's like a
horror film in the sense that you know
those those Girl Talk albums it's like a
dance song right but all these with all
these samples so there's all these
various genres to make you know a dance
track so this is a horror movie and
we're sampling all these different
genres I mean there's comedy I mean we
there's moments of absurdist comedy you
know and then and then there's
incredibly dark stuff there's it's
everything so and we try to go in
through the script it was like you know
bounce it out how so that this keeps
working there has to be consistency in
structures so I you do all this work to
make sure that there's there's balance
when you are sort of doing that so that
when we're on set we can have fun and I
I never had more fun ever making a movie
ever
like they truly I don't say like a nice
thing because feels weird but like I
like they I love them like we had so
much fun together
I'd never have never never had such a
good time I don't understand someone who
makes a movie and doesn't have fun
making it or doesn't encourage them you
kind of vine you gotta try it you got to
make a movie
one of the most difficult experiences of
my life it was very challenging but I
adore the people that were around me and
I had one ad in one of my film school
student shorts and he used to say all
the time when everyone would get
stressed out he would stop and he would
look to the Grippit he'd be like guys
we're making a movie because you still
have there's still like a glow about you
I lost that a long time ago all know
what you have that very he would feel
you know how the productions go on and
to be late and whatnot you had that
enthusiasm you brought what he would
always remind us of what we were doing
and and she had a great attitude I mean
I've been doing this long frickin time
and it's it's not fun when you do it
with people that don't appreciate the
fact that you're being given this
opportunity to make this movie because
it's not something you're born with it's
not a right you had to make a movie and
you're not entitled to it you earn it
you're given it so you got to be
grateful for that and he is and and
reminded us and it's important because
if you lose track of that that I mean
there's nothing I love more movies yeah
and it's apparent and and I think that's
why this movie is such you know I love
the fact that we were all out there on
the on the edge without a net yeah and
that's an exhilarating experience as a
performer to to feel that and you don't
always get that in film
is there any particular scene in this
movie where you're on set and you're
kind of like what am i doing right now
and then you saw it in the final cut and
you're like oh like that wound up really
working the piano scene yeah the
infamous piano scene was like the
weirdest scene but it was my favorite
scene it's my favorite scene that we
shot like I had so much fun doing it but
it was a very vulnerable experience
because while you're doing it
you have no idea what you're doing and
if this plays and if this works how this
fits into this world and just the whole
setup of it's it's so bizarre
and so so much fun I really thought the
producers being nervous father Chanel
are you able to play piano at all I took
a couple years when I was seven so I
know like some basics of mary had a
little lamb
but yeah beyond that a class you're
awful just plain oh that that seemed was
fun it was a it was a little it was like
dancing with her it was I I had a great
time with that whole scene she's
terrific and you added a line from your
high school PE teacher I headed a line
from my high school PE teacher I did
yeah we kept it back in the day when men
were men and women knew it yeah that's
the generation I'm from we had a lot of
stuff we schools in the watching last
night the reaction I have on screen was
the same reaction I had watching them
just like the yawn but that the weirdest
scene for me I don't know how do you
phrase the question but I think that
yeah I can't remember exactly how it was
but was knocking on the door to the
serial killers mm-hmm motel and doing
that that was a fun scene for me to do
because we kind of came at it from a way
that we didn't think we were gonna come
at it and it was surprising how I felt
like it worked
dude that wasn't you though then we did
this and it got a little weird and I
felt bad and said to Rick he like really
stuck with me these characters they stay
with you and I don't know I don't know
if that's a good thing with this
is there any characters the two of you
have played over the years that have
stuck with you more than most I feel
like a lot of very sweet it's true and I
you know I'm my career's shorter but
it's not super short and but I feel like
most of my characters have all been the
same ish and that's why I wanted to do
this similar with Robert was I was this
is such a departure for me I never get
to play kind of the messy girl like I'm
always the put together girl next door
which is so boring to me
take note Hollywood but and so that's
why I wanted to do this was because it
was an opportunity to play so opposite
what I usually get to do so I forget
what the question was but me and Robert
are having a hard time remembering
undersell final destination 3 and I
actually I actually say I say that in
the most sincere way because the
collider viewers know I have a deep
obsession with that franchise and I
genuinely well that was my first movie
ever and I'm still best friends with
Mary Elizabeth Winstead and that's what
I thought every movie was was you became
best friends with the lead actress like
that you would always I quickly learned
movies after that you don't get to be
best friends with everyone you work with
but she's still a very very very close
friend great experience is there any
part that you've played of the many many
that has stuck with you where you've
taken a piece of that character with you
probably probably I can't I can't find
anything that sticks out in my mind
right now
not the faculty not to figure that was
fun
I yeah that was like dropping all the
movies Robert Rodriguez and the Omni
Hotel we shot a scene there with my
family when I was a teeny-tiny child and
that was part of my obsession right
there Spy Kids we
shut that here that's Robert yes well
the faculty was fun does he oh that's
cool by the other day oh that's cool
he's a good guy
yeah I'm sure there's stuff that stuck
with me
but this yeah this is this was
interesting it's not an easy one to
shake off especially if you're somebody
who wears contact lenses so thank you
for that I have to wrap this up right
now
yeah that's gonna be ingrained in my
head for quite some time spider
tone-deaf keep an eye out for it thank
you so much for your time today you seem
to like movies that makes me so happy
it's a little mechanical that you really
have joy in your heart I do and I
genuinely appreciate the fact that I get
to sit here and I never forget that so
thank you for so cool not to me you guys
mean a lot to me to like and share this
video and don't forget hint water what
did we call the wine again line 39 okay
and Commissario tequila you guys Rock
thank you for letting us talk about
movies like tone deaf see you soon with
more interviews from South by Southwest
2019
you